la tragedia se juntaron en india este
lunes las autoridades apenas inician el
recuento de los daños que dejó el ciclón
total la tormenta más poderosa en dos
décadas que llegó en medio de otro pico
de pandemia
el ciclón salto la vida de decenas de
personas mientras las autoridades buscan
a más de 50 desaparecidos tras hundirse
un barco en mumbai producto del mal
tiempo no habíamos perdido toda la
esperanza de seguir con vida no
pensábamos que nos iban a rescatar la
armada de india informó que 183 personas
fueron rescatadas en las últimas 24
horas aunque lo peor ha pasado según las
autoridades
actualmente el ciclo se ha debilitado a
un nivel de tormenta ciclónica y
probablemente en un par de horas se
convertirá en tormenta ciclónica que es
una categoría más baja
[Música]
el ciclón generó vientos sostenidos de
hasta 210 kilómetros y causó la
evacuación de unas 150.000 personas la
mayoría están retornando a sus hogares
pero los servicios de salud atienden
otra emergencia la de kobe 19 pero se
han visto limitados por los daños en
carreteras este miércoles india registró
un nuevo récord el superar las 4500
muertes diarias por la pandemia el
colapso del sistema sanitario y la
escasez de suministros han limitado la
jornada de vacunación apenas un 3% de la
población ha sido vacunada en un país de
más de 1300 millones de habitantes